- And that's why you vote for Deutch.
- (laughing) Yes, a vote
for Deutch is a vote
for the puppies.
That's nice.
- Gosh, that was good.
- Yeah, I'll be your co-running mate.
- Thanks.
- Yeah (laughing).
- Hi, I'm Gina.
I'm here with Zooey Duetch from
"The Politician", and
these are her Netflix IX.
(funky music)
So you play Infinity,
which is obviously Payton's running mate,
but a large portion of your time on-screen
is with Jessica Lange.
Icon.
She is.
Talk to me about Ms. Lange,
what was it like working with her?
- A dream.
- Don't eat that fast.
You're going to yack it
all up like a baby bird.
Spit it out.
Oh, Christ, look at that.
Jesus.
- I love her so much and
it was such a rewarding
and special experience working with her,
and I was just doing my best to be as much
of a sponge as I could
and soak up the Langeness.
- On Instagram, you have a highlight,
which I love, called...
No I'm not going to bring out
any weird receipts (laughs)
I won't go back to 2008, no.
- Yeah.
(laughing)
- No, kidding, kidding.
- That wasn't me.
(laughing).
- You've got a highlight
called stuff I'm bad at.
- Oh, yeah.
- Which--
- There's a lot of that,
but what's on that one.
- Which shows you been
terrible at charades.
- Oh, god, that was humiliating.
- What's something else
that you're famously bad at?
- Everything, everything
- That's... Stop that.
- And also any like "Two in
the bush one in the bag."
Give me one... what is it like...
- Like can't...
You can take a horse to water
but you can't make a drink.
Stuff like that?
- Yeah, I would say like,
"You can take a horse to get milk
"but it won't drink it."
And people would be like,
"That's not a thing."
- I'm interested to know,
who's the most fascinating
character that you have played?
- I think in the last year
I got to play Infinity
and then right after that I played...
It's a character named
Madison in Zombieland 2,
and jumping from those two
is really fascinating for me.
That was...
There couldn't be...
They couldn't be more polar opposite.
Infinity is diminutive
and ill and isolated.
A lot of nice people heard about my chemo
and they paid for me to go
to Disneyland with my Nana
and we got to skip all of the
lines and it was so much fun.
(laughing)
Best day ever.
And then I played
Madison who's essentially
a amalgamation of or a version
of Paris Hilton in 2009.
With big long fake nails
and long blonde hair and
juice good tracks.
So getting to get those two
very distinct different voices
and looks and perspectives that was
so so rewarding and fun.
- I have a question to ask you about
your parents and Ed Sheeran's
music video, "Perfect."
- I thought you said my
parents in Ed Sheeran's video.
I was like, "Did my parents...
(laughing)
- They're here (laughing).
- I was like, "My parents in
an Ed Sheeran's music video?"
- Ed Sheeran also is here.
That video has over two
billion views on YouTube but--
- Does it?
- Yes.
- Wow.
Can you tell me how that happened?
How did you--
- I don't know, he was
like, "Zoey, come to Austria
"And film this music video."
And I said, "Sure Ed, that's do it."
And it was filmed in this
little ski town in Austria
called Hintertux because
he wanted to make it
a Christmas video,
even though there was a lyric that says,
"Barefoot in the grass."
I'm like this doesn't...
Like barefoot in the grass and we're just
frolicking through the snowy woods.
I was just like, "Okay, whatever."
I've no explanation
other than he was like,
"Will you come do this
music video in Austria?"
I was like, "Yeah, okay sure."
- "The Politician" is a
show that has a lot of heart
but it's also hilarious.
- We could make some money on this?
- Absolutely.
Oh, absolutely.
- Oh, well hot damn.
- Were there an scenes
where you kept laughing
or had to stop yourself from laughing?
- There's a part of a scene
that didn't make it into the show
because Ben and I could
not get our shit together
in any way, shape or form
and it was a very very...
It was a three word improv ad-lib
that Jessica Lange did about
the ingredients in her dish,
which was a bologna cup.
- It smells great.
- Well?
- Bologna cups.
Yay.
Velveeta cheese and bologna.
That was all she said and
the way that she said it
with all of her Langeness
had Ben and I crying of laughter.
The whole crew crying with laughter.
- "The Politician" centers
obviously around rival
political campaigns.
If you were running for
student body president,
what obscure thing would
you promise people?
- First period would be puppy period,
and you would spend it with
all slew of cute ass dogs.
(laughing)
- That's actually really...
You'd win.
That's so nice.
- Yeah, right?
Everyday would start with a puppy.
- Do you have a secret talent?
- I have one and I show
it in every interview
so it's so boring but I'm
so bad at so many things
and I'm really only good
at one skill that is
useless.
And it's making myself look
like I have a facelift.
- I have seen this
but I really want to see it again, please.
- Okay.
(laughing)
- What's a job that you
should you could do if money
and skill were no option?
I told you there were answers that short.
- Neuroscientist.
Just because that sounds smart.
- That sounds really cool, yeah.
- And my job sounds the opposite of smart.
- That's not true.
- No.
What about you, what would you do?
I told you you'd get excentral.
- Yeah, I know, you're right.
No you're right.
You know what.
I weirdly wanted to be
a synchronized swimmer
when I was younger.
- That's so cool.
- Yeah.
- Have you ever done it?
- Well, I used to swim and
then I was just like lazy
and I was like, "Forget it."
You know, it's like when you are trying
to be like a pro at stuff.
That's long.
So I left it but I still
kind of want to do that.
- But they have like groups of...
You can go and do synchronized
swimmer like things.
- Yeah, that's true.
- There's one in LA, I know for sure.
I was looking into it
with a friend of mine.
- Oh, okay.
- Because I'd thought it'd be
a weird, fun hobby to have.
- There you go.
So if you were forced to do an ice breaker
in a room full of new people
and you're ought to tell
the group one interesting
fact about yourself,
what fact would you choose?
- I hate revolving doors
and scallops and everything
else is pretty tolerable
or even good and exciting.
- Why don't you like revolving doors?
- They're going to get you.
- Yeah, they actually are, though.
Like they really are.
- They're going to get you.
They're going to get you.
That's what they do, they get you.
- Okay, Zoey thank you so
much for speaking with me.
- Thank you.
- Have a great time.
I love "The Politician" by the way.
You're fantastic in it.
- Thank you.
- And these were your Netflix IX.
- Netflix IX.